they warned us that something was coming
if there is ever an end in this forever
war it will be because of you and your
strong right hand you calling monster
pal you looking at me recently
Oh God you've arrived just in time
hey everybody we finally got that
Hellboy footage a day early
IGN dropped this trailer so I guess they
wanted it to post early whatever we'll
break it down if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos the movies coming out next
year but there'll be plenty more
trailers before that happens
ok so David Harbour wielding Excalibur
on fire Milla Jovovich who's playing
NEMA way the Lady of the lake aka the
greatest of all British witches who is
the main villain of this movie so if it
wasn't clear who she's playing and you
haven't read any of the Hellboy comics
I'll try to explain because I think this
is based somewhat on the Wild Hunt and
they're using that as a sort of
transition from the guillermo del toro
movies to explain how everything looks a
little bit different so at the beginning
of that story Hellboy has been trapped
in another world by another group he
comes back so he has to sort of
reintroduce himself to all these other
people in McShane as you can see is
playing his father professor Brunton
home
so it's an r-rated reimagining of the
Hellboy character that's why you meet
all the BPRD characters and you actually
go to the BPRD for the first time like
he makes the joke about the entrance in
the trailer they probably won't dedicate
quite as much time during this movie to
his origin story as the original
Guillermo del Toro movies did the
beginning of that movie started with the
Nazis summoning him to earth because
he's a really cool character but there's
this long term prophecy about him
bringing about the destruction of the
world with the right hand of doom that's
what as big giant hand is called
so of course we got to say a David
Harbor looks very different sounds very
different from the Ron Perlman Hellboy I
have a very special place in my heart
for those movies the first one I still
think is the best one but the story that
it seems like they picked to base this
new r-rated version on sounds like it's
going to be much bigger if you haven't
read the Wild Hunt and you don't know
about Hellboy wielding Excalibur it's
actually a pretty cool story but you
hear ian mcshane give you a little bit
of a teaser for the overarching story
when he talks about the forever war and
you see Hellboy walking to retrieve
Excalibur if you're not familiar with
Hellboy mythology this incorporates a
lot of the mythology of the King Arthur
Chronicles you know in real life Arthur
Pendragon knights of the round table
Camelot all that so within the world of
Hellboy the rules
wielding Excalibur is is it only
descendants genetic descendants of King
Arthur Pendragon can pull the sword out
of the stone sometimes it will disappear
for centuries then reappear so it
reappears during this story in hell boy
is able to retrieve it surprised because
he is the descendant of King Arthur
marking him as the rightful king of
Britain so Hellboy who sort of like this
Prince of Hell like he has the crown of
flames that you save during the chemo
del'toro movies the crown of flames is
also a nice reference to being the
rightful king of Britain that enables
him to wield Excalibur and because of
his demonic abilities that's why he's
able to light the sword on fire but even
if you're familiar with the King Arthur
Chronicles because this is the world of
Hellboy and it's sort of their spin on
the King Arthur mythology the sword
gives Hellboy a lot of extra powers so
because he's a rightful king of Britain
wielding the sword he actually gets to
resurrect a lot of dead British Knights
to fight for him in this big war against
NIM away the story of her character is a
little more complex I don't know how
much of it they're gonna do from the
comic book but she was the most powerful
British Witch in history but kind of a
villain kind of crazy so what happened
is is that when she was killed they had
to separate her body into a bunch of
different pieces because she was so
powerful that if you laid her corpse
pieces on top of each other they would
just reform her body and she would be
resurrected so you basically have to
chop her body up and put all the pieces
in different boxes so that her body
can't reform so when the British witches
in present-day
need a strong leader they ask Hellboy he
refuses they choose her and then grant a
couple people permission to reform her
body and bring her back to life but
because she's so powerful the dragons of
the Apocalypse that have been in prison
to choose her as their vessel to return
to Earth and destroy everything which i
think is what this scene in the trailer
is meant to imply the dragon flying over
what looks like London set on fire
because obviously a lot of this feels
very British because they're doing
Excalibur they're doing the King Arthur
Chronicles British mythology so it makes
sense that the story takes place in
England but if you're not familiar with
the dragons of the Apocalypse is
basically the Hellboy comics spin on the
Book of Revelations so in the Christian
Bible is this big wreck
for planet earth but in the Hellboy
comics is through these special dragons
that were imprisoned a long time ago by
the right hand of do remember the hand
that Hellboy has attached to his body so
what we might wind up with in this movie
this is just me speculating is is that
Hellboy wielding Excalibur will fight
Milla Jovovich as nimel a character who
becomes possessed by the Dragons of the
revelations so you literally have
Hellboy Dragon Slayer with Excalibur so
the story feels like a very classic
British myth like we just got that guy
ritchie king arthur film it didn't go
over so well but everybody has very well
intention so this is just a slightly
different spin on that idea but
obviously that's just a quick once-over
and the trailer doesn't give you a real
big idea for how deep this goes so if
you're big fan of really cool mythology
like that i would recommend checking out
some of the Hellboy comics starting with
the Wild Hunt there are only a couple
things about the trailer that bother me
I'm not super hot on the pop song that
they chose in some of the corny jokes
that they tried to incorporate into this
if you're really bummed out the
Guillermo del Toro is involved with this
don't worry I believe he's given his
blessing Ron Perlman has also given his
blessing to David Harper David Harper is
a great actor they're definitely
swinging for the fence with the story in
the scope that they're going with so
it'll be interesting to see some of the
subsequent trailers usually the first
teaser trailer doesn't give you a really
big idea about the story but like I said
I think this is largely based on the
Wild Hunt the Hellboy comics
incorporating a lot of the King Arthur
mythology into their stories is also a
re-explore a recon textual ization of
Hellboy's origin story itself so even
though it's not the origin story that we
got with the guillermo del toro first
movie it's still an origin story of
sorts so I think they're trying to use
it as a jumping-off point for people who
may have never seen that original
Hellboy film so we'll see how far they
go with it because if it does well
they'll probably do sequels so we'll see
where they continue but let me know in
the comments which our favorite part of
the trailer and what are you looking
forward to most if you are a big hell
boy comic book fan to let me know what's
your favorite comic book story while you
wait for everything click here for a
bunch of brand new Game of Thrones
Season 8 promos and click here for my
brand new Avengers endgame video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight